Please welcome Asad Syrkett.
(audience applauding)
Welcome.
Thank you so much for having me.
This is major, so thank you so much for having me.
I am so starstruck right now.
I'm not kidding.
Stop it.
No, you don't--
First of all, I'm a subscriber.
Okay, well thank you.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate that.
I love your talent.
I love watching your journey
as the Editor in Chief of Elle Decor.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
I can't wait to pick your brain.
Will you get into some headlines with us?
Please.
Okay! Asad, you actually have the first one, take it away.
All right.
So first we're going to talk about something very personal,
the art we hang on the walls of our home.
Study Finds reports a new survey found 42% of people
say the art in their home is museum worthy.
The survey found the most common category
of art is the landscape followed by photography.
And in third place are things with sentimental value
like portraits or vintage signs and posters.
So Drew and Ross, what are your favorite are pieces
of art you have hanging at home?
I don't think anything I have is museum worthy
unless you can get that at Home Goods,
I'm sorry, I don't have it.
(audience laughing)
You know, I like the personal stuff, you know,
like when one of Willie's friends got us,
it's like at the stop sign street intersection
it says my last name and his last name, you know?
And it's just right there in our kitchen.
It's so beautiful.
Yeah.
'Cause it's so personal to us.
Exactly.
Yeah, what about you Drew?
I bet you have amazing art.
I am a huge collector, but nothing I own is expensive.
I love that.
When it comes to art, I really agree that
it just isn't the dollar amount,
it's what it means to you,
it's how it speaks to you.
There's really no wrong or right when it comes to art.
And I think people should feel
like theirs this museum worthy.
I totally agree.
(audience applauding)
Design expert here,
I'm not the only design expert up here.
Yeah.
Clearly.
What about you?
What is your personal philosophy?
It's great to hear you both talk
about sentimentality and sentimental value with art.
Because the thing for me in my apartment
that I love is actually a concert poster
someone gave me from a 1982 Luther Vandros concert.
Oh wow.
Luther Vandros and Cheryl Lynn in concert in Los Angeles.
And it still has like the fraying edges
and it's some like texture
and I love it and it's bright orange and blue.
And so I walk into my--
To my foyer at home and it's just
like the first thing I see.
Color.
And it's so great and the color is so sunny
and it's like right by my office at home.
If you like it-- I won't say if you like it, it's good.
But if you like it, that means it has value for you.
Well, here's what we say in our world.
We say it's cute for you.
It's cute for you.
Very that.
Very that, very that.
All right, well next up we got a magic little design trick
you may not have thought of,
The Wall Street Journal reports design pros say
you can jazz up any closet with some funky wallpaper.
Yes, just 'cause you're outta the closet
doesn't mean you can't go back there to spruce it up.
(laughing)
And the bolder, the better.
Look, people are using bright and busy prints,
wild patterns and taking big risks
with color in tiny spaces.
Okay, so what do you think about this trend?
That's a great idea.
I wholeheartedly agree that when you come out
you should actually be bigger and bolder,
more colorful than you were before.
And not just closets, but also powder rooms
and other small spaces in your home.
It could be a pantry,
it could be, you know, just a corner like your entryway
if you have a small apartment.
And it's a way to really experiment and have fun with color
and pattern and texture in a space where it's low stakes.
And it means that, you know, if it doesn't work
you can just say, I don't like that.
That's great.
Low stakes, smaller spaces.
I decoupaged
vintage maps all over my closet
and we call it the map closet
and it a closet that kind of houses
the majority of our stuff in the house
and it brings so much joy.
Sounds great.
It's great.
It's really helpful 'cause it's like center.
Well next up our design guru,
our resident design expert here at the show,
Makel Welch was here earlier this week.
I asked Makel, what for him
is his favorite trend in design right now?
And he said the black accents.
Then we found this story
and it takes it to a whole new level.
Apartment Therapy, one of my very favorite sites,
reports for just $250,000
you can get the all black house,
the goth of your dreams, if you will.
It's a two room in Lincoln, Illinois.
All the walls are black with white trim,
black flooring, black in the bedrooms.
But it also has a lot of light.
The home is built in an octagon shape.
Sun does flood in the windows
to sort of counterbalance the darkness.
Thoughts, Asad?
I mean we knew black was chic.
This is a lot but I'm actually into it
because it's a choice, right?
Like somebody said, I'm gonna go for this and they did it.
And I so respect that even if
I don't wanna live in that type of environment.
I so respect that.
(audience applauding)
You know, I'm the one with white walls
and I'm actually really into this.
I wanna like curl up Netflix
for a whole whole day in this house.
It just, it looks like it cozy,
that's the word to me.
Can you believe into it?
See I--
No, I cannot, Rossy.
I'm shocked you like this house.
I'm shocked I like it too.
When I heard about it, I was like, no.
And then I saw the picture. I was like, oh.
It's kind of the opposite of what you have now, right?
It's like just the spiritual opposite
of your current situation.
So maybe that's part of the appeal.
Yeah, and you know, it's--
You know, we have the whole masculine thing in common,
that sort of dark brooding bad boy thing.
(upbeat music)